are you interested in in engineering in
any way or do you have an analytical
mind uh i've been told that i think i do
by professionals uh by by the very
misses i was unleashing my right my
serpentines
i'm glad i'm glad somebody's clapping
they're applauding your penis
she's fantastic she co-produced the
sherlock holmes movie though didn't she
yeah yeah she sends her regards and
having another baby yeah another one so
another team danny production
when is this
that one i i had much less to do with
than the movie
i was only involved for about seven
minutes
[Applause]
uh and and do you have the moves you
have some uh do you use it in uh
fighting situations or is it just for
training
uh yeah it's it's actually martial arts
are designed for fighting i'm told yeah
so if i came at you now would you be
ready to defend yourself i would waste
you in a second
uh consternation you had a little bit of
doubt yeah i'm coming into the marvel
universe yeah you did why because you'd
done it before you've been well no it
was just it was a big commitment you
know these these contracts are you know
six nine movies long it's not a guy who
likes to be held down ladies
[Laughter]
who is the biggest diva in the whole
cast
oh why do you say she feels like she
knows what answer do you think you know
yeah well who who do you think it is
okay i want to know what she thinks yeah
who do you think
oh you think it's robert
get that [ __ ] off the monitor
okay
[Applause]
what did you do what did you do for 50.
you know 65. 65. all right so 15 years
from now yeah all right or no no wait
what are we talking about 60. yeah
you're right so what what did you do
uh we rented out an airplane hangar wow
and
and then uh we paid the bill
that's a trigger and memo they are pygmy
goats and they are also brother lovers
oh yeah oh very modern it's perfect yeah
do these come in the house
uh
not when they're active okay
please come enjoy dog face for dinner
usually i have a donkey vagina for
dinner
yesterday i have cat face for breakfast
[Applause]
here we go you know evans is a very
very capable guy i mean you know chicks
dig them too
but what is halo time though it's it's
have you ever played do you play them no
but i've heard people who are playing it
to the exclusion of all other activities
and uh
i have a day job as well right yeah yeah
well you but you used to get involved in
other activities even though you had a
day job
please tell me if this is true that you
had your furniture from home shipped to
atlanta so you would have your own
furniture while you were there i didn't
do a thing the moving company
and were you surprised at how you looked
i mean you are a beautiful man there's
no denying that uh i
it's true i would i would
i would probably kick myself out of bed
i look like if my sister was on a round
of steroids
before you start filming the movies
what's the thing you get most excited
about
probably my first costume fitting me
surrounded
by many full-length mirrors
oh yes
i'm sorry
i was
oh that was good
sorry
he smelled my stuff
i must be mellowing with age but i want
to say this very clearly the next time
i'm not asked the first question
[Applause]
you know it's a schedule i got my
cousin's wedding and
dad's 70th birthday and the whole the
whole deal yeah and and how will we
celebrate dad's 70th birthday uh well he
had a little party and i showed up
pretty good
you know mentors are important did you
have one growing up uh rodney
dangerfield he really showed me the
ropes was he really your mentor
he's still in depression
i've had a bunch of uh regular jobs but
i think i think i had sticky fingers if
i'm not mistaken
is that why the jobs didn't last that
long well one i've kept jobs for a while
it just depends on how long it takes
them to find out
are you looking forward to the process
of being a father again i think so yeah
what kind of stuff do you do to prepare
uh
yeah
like that
that's all it takes
because you do movies which are
normally more personal movies normally
more quirky movies stranger films you
know you've done a few of the big budget
ones but in recent years i've noticed
you've gone for
you know slightly more intellectual fare
right what was the temptation for you to
get into a movie like this
i don't know why but i thought maybe i'd
like to be in a movie that more than 16
people would see
is gentleman here in the front row thank
you
i'm sorry it's been 15 minutes since my
last wardrobe
[Laughter]
[Applause]
jimmy jimmy
you keep me up all through the night
until
[Music]
not this movie this movie
is uh
avengers age of ultron that's right and
that's the new film now the next film we
think
captain america you're in that one is
that correct that's right dave you'll be
playing
i can't stop doing these movies i love
them yeah
and you fight captain america yes right
well it's called civil war
and uh there was a strain of comics
where captain america and uh an iron man
they went on different sides and they
they fought each other evil enemies
i don't i wouldn't call either of them
evil but they wanted control yeah
uh and who you you
do you win you must win i bet you win
right
have you done that movie yet no no i'm
going to go start shooting that one in a
couple weeks okay um well it's called
captain america civil war
captain america can i have spiderman in
there as well uh he may well be yeah i
hear that they're they're looking to
cast a
new spider-man yeah who do we root for
captain america iron man or something
that's up to the people
[Laughter]
that's people
[Laughter]
they put that up there oh
that's interesting arthur conan doyle
died in 1930 71 years old he was
[Applause]
you're probably wondering how do they
know that
because we are crazy but in a different
way
[Music]
you